republicans demanding answers while the
white house refuses to talk about
president biden's controversial july
phone call with then-afghan president
ghani we're getting new details of that
leaked transcript where the president
pressured the afghan leader to say the
taliban wasn't winning ghani reportedly
telling biden mr president we are facing
a full-scale invasion republicans now
want the full transcript at least and
are slamming president biden over the
phone call
it's just one example of the disastrous
miscalculations that brought us to where
we are now with hundreds of americans
left behind in afghanistan because of
joe biden's feckless execution of his
decision to withdraw they don't call him
quid pro joe for nothing and the most
horrible thing about all of this tammy
is that he the fact that he had the lie
means that he knew six weeks ago
that things were going to go bad that's
correct he didn't he didn't adjust his
strategy he didn't warn americans in
that country to leave
meantime white house press secretary jen
saki is being called a hypocrite for
refusing to give any details about that
call
was the president in any way pushing a
false narrative in that call with the
afghan president i think it's pretty
clear again i'm not going to go into
details of a private conversation but
what we saw over the course of the last
few months is a collapse in leadership
and that was happening even before ghani
left the country
greg no
we'll get to you in a second back in
2019 sake cared a whole lot about phone
calls when it came to president trump's
chat with ukrainian president zielinski
saki tweeted
if it is not just the call transcript
the whistleblower complaint would likely
have more details we need both
and it's not just the call what did you
utter greg
when they when they said it was a
collapse of leadership i was trying to
figure out which country she was
referring to yes or he was referring do
you want to continue what you want okay
sure uh
why is this lie important uh
it it kind of tells you how regular
lying is in this process that we've been
lied to for so long how can a war last
20 years
it's it can if it's tolerable to a point
of almost invisibility so you we've had
20 super bowls of this you know 20
christmases how is that possible the
secret to a long war is settling in and
making it mildly okay through fibbing
everything's going well oh the war is
great everything's fine it's the lie
that kept this thing going so even and
he did i mean he did like what he did
was unethical is it impeachment level i
don't think so but then again i'm not a
liberal i'm not a democrat i don't work
at cnn where everything was impeachable
and i mean i suppose i you know you know
it turned what does it turn about is
fair play you know we people should be
shouting for impeachment but i think
what bothers me is that it's just
another sign that the entire picture was
never ever told and it's never told to
us and that's why i think this why
afghanistan fell so fast uh because
these happy little stories were for us
and not them
it will
listen jen sake
you don't respond to a question if you
don't have a good answer and she doesn't
have a good answer for this because
she's full of hypocrisy it's hard to
answer questions when you have to
account with yourself from a previous
time period and let's play the previous
time period game for just a moment let's
play the switch the hat game you brought
up impeachment if this were president
trump right would there be a push for
impeachment i think we know the answer
is yes if this phone call didn't happen
it was simply the afghanistan debacle
under president trump would there be a
push for impeachment absolutely i think
i think a story we're going to do a
little bit later if two top fda
executives resigned under president
trump would there be a massive
controversy the answer would be yes so
clearly we're not playing by the same
rules that we were a year ago but really
quickly on the lie we need to lay out
exactly how cynical this is what this
reveals is that president baide knew the
nature of what was going down in
afghanistan he knew how bad it was so he
made decisions knowing the potential
consequences we can play the degree
games was he sure exactly how bad it
would be but he made a calculation to
accept that chaos and i think that he
made that calculation because he thought
he could play the blame game and lay it
off on president trump that has failed
the lie failed
jeff the poll numbers let me just bring
these in
as they fall dropped to 43 percent in
the new poll the npr pbs newshour poll
and uh the the facts are we know that
the intelligence community warned
president biden even before he announced
the withdrawal in april
that the afghan national army would
collapse and so again why why the
cover-up what's the political gain
because clearly that was the motive
well so far we won't know what the
political gain is for quite some time
right until we get closer to the
midterms because this is a huge hot
button issue right now then we have the
texas abortion case that came down in
the last couple of days and that's now
front and center and that's really
activating liberals who were kind of
sitting around saying we don't actually
love the way we exited out of this this
was the right policy decision we don't
like it so
go ahead and then i'll interrupt you go
ahead
i'm excited just give me like 40 seconds
i think is all that i need for this one
um okay the poll numbers are obviously
slipping they are not as low as
president trump's were at this point um
and president obama actually never hit
this point until the third year of his
presidency so both trump and biden are
struggling more than obama was
necessarily but to the point about this
phone call and the quote cover-up of it
president trump asked for a personal
favor from the leader of another country
he didn't say something to zielinski
about having anything to do with
diplomatic relations he asked the
ukrainian president to dig up dirt on
his political opponent so that he could
win a presidential election that is why
that is impeachable if biden had said
hey president ghani say that everything
is going well and also if you could dig
up dirt on tom cotton he's getting a
little hot you know i think maybe he
might be running in 2024 then we would
be talking about impeachment and i
believe that every single liberal who
advocated for it with president trump
would do that with president biden but
that's not what it happened here and i
was listening to andy mccarthy talk to
you this morning on mornings with maria
and he said i don't see anything wrong
with this call between biden and ghani
impeachment but it is so it's not about
the use of the office but the call
itself is deeply troubling given the
fact that biden has lied over and over
again to the american people about what
went down blaming everybody but himself
for literally the death of 13 of
american troops
of service members and that's what's so
appalling is and there is a need whether
it's true or not there's a need to
project a different picture which is
what he is still doing even after the
fact well and it gets to will's point i
think that i think we all know if this
was the previous administration people
would be outraged i think everybody
should be outraged and rightly are right
now that we've lost 13 people who are
brave in service to this country but i
think the reaction would be obviously
different from the mainstream media and
how it was handled but the american
people don't like to be played for
suckers i think that's reflected in the
poll numbers they don't want to think
that you're telling them one thing when
you might believe something else whether
it's about covet and mask and french
laundry and whatever is going on and
people are going to have more questions
about okay the vetting is an example do
we know that people are being fully and
thoroughly vetted as they should i got a
message from a former military pilot who
now flies commercial flew one of these
big jets out of there he said we thought
we were on this great humanitarian
mission then when we got to the states
we were stuck for hours on the tarmac at
dulles airport outside of dc because
these people hadn't been vetted we had
to sit there for hours with crying
babies and barefoot people and people
who hadn't eaten you know or had
something to drink and he said they
weren't tested for covet either so when
you don't tell people the full truth and
we're saying now things like these
people are fully vetted everything's
good to go they're gonna have questions
about everything you say why would you
leave hundreds of reporters behind why
would you leave a majority of
translators behind if this was was
planned just a couple more things
somebody leaked this transcript
and there are people who are pissed off
within this administration and don't you
expect that more and more of this is
going to come out
yeah and i mean it just
it's just weird it's like when you're
looking at how
we've abandoned our afghan allies
especially all you can say is what did
you expect from a racist country run by
a racist president
oh wait wait whoa whoa i thought i was
at cnn and trump was president cause
that's exactly what i would say
well and you got to think in in
washington people will start to turn on
each other i mean the pentagon the white
house the intel community they're all
going to be leaking as they point
fingers at each other no one wants to
get thrown under the bus over this so i
predict more leaks to come i have one
more thing to say before we go you look
at this transcript it shows joe biden
very much in charge of what was going on
so he is not the cream of wheat slurpin
cognitive remember she said that the
next time you say this don't knock dream
of wheat one of the underrated breakfast
treats not brown sugar yeah
gruel
slurping
cognitive don't don't bash the
cognitively gone guy hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else